robin and i have um
robin and i have an employee we call her
a nanny she comes over she helps with
caring for the kids and she helps with
schooling the kids she's over all the
time so her she doesn't go anywhere her
husband's the only one that does the
shopping so i don't understand why
isabelle can come over and hang out
she's devastated
what
is
the nanny and her husband doing
that makes it so they can come over
because when i'm home
i do exactly what i should
yet my girls
can't see their siblings
what
does the nanny
do
we're all as safe as can be i think that
it's time to lift the restrictions
she's not keeping the same rules she's
not doing the same thing she's so full
it's been six months and we're not doing
well
we're not doing well
i need to guarantee that we really are
going to thanksgiving otherwise i'm
leaving i guess
okay leave that out tomorrow
let's let's bring the family to a
consensus on what we're gonna do
okay
we are at an impasse we
disagree i'm just done with this
conversation
i'm done
we are not making any progress here and
i'm hoping that tomorrow i can come back
and maintain my argument
or maybe get some backup
i just can't i don't i've got to go
okay
all right so hopefully i'll be able to
see so this afternoon depending on where
i'm at if you'll let me know what's
going on with isabel
okay maybe i can
figure this out okay okay all right
we'll see you later all right bye
good talk
i don't know if cody even wants to see
everybody all together again i'm really
seriously worried about that maybe his
finest living separate
i think it would be great if everybody
maintained
our
covid protocols
so that we could all be together that
would be awesome
but so far there's no indicators that
everybody's willing to do that
what we have
is a fundamental breakdown of trust in
the family
[Music]
you